this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
light so good morning welcome to lecture
number 22 of the international winter
school um today we'll turn to a
discussion of black holes and in
particular the Schwarz Shield black hole
now um if you uh couldn't be here for
the last six lectures uh that's not a
problem because what we do today only
depends on lectures 1 to 15 um
so uh there's a fresh start if you wish
and uh the same will be true on
Wednesday when there will be again a
fresh start so uh now the topics stop
being being dependent totally on
everything that happened before uh so
maybe that gives you some comfort in
studying this now what we wish to do
here in this lecture is uh to study the
Schwarz Shield
solution and you saw the Schwarz Shield
solution and in fact you verified that
the Schwarz Shield solution is a vacuum
solution um of einin
equations you saw this in tutorials
right and what you checked there is that
you if you plug in the following metric
G being a 02 tensor can be written as 1
minus 2 m over R where this little m is
short for capital g capital M where this
is called the mass of the Schwarz Shield
SpaceTime and G is Newton's
gravitational
constant you can write it like this DT
tensor DT or in other words in
coordinates where T is one coordinate
it's the first entry of the Matrix for
the T in those coordinates um minus 1
over 1 - 2 m / R Dr R tensor d r minus r
2 D Theta tensor D theta plus sin s
Theta D 10
D or again as I said in other words it's
a diagonal metric in coordinates t r
Theta F where the diagonal entries are
this Factor this one minus r 2 and minus
r 2 sin 2 Theta you check that this is a
vacuum solution uh in a chart in the
so-called Schwartz
Shield
coordinates so the metric is called the
Schwarz Shield metric and that refers to
the G but the coordinates in which this
is formulated are maybe unfortunately
also called Schwarz Shield coordinates
of course you could express the Schwarz
Shield metric in non Schwarz Shield
coordinates but here the Schwarz Shield
metric is expressed in Schwarz Shield
coordinates and those are coordinates t
r Theta and F and the T can take values
from minus infin inity to Infinity R can
take values from 0 to Infinity Theta
from 0 to Pi and five from 0 to 2 pi now
we will be careful to keep track of the
ranges of variables here because you
remember that in the beginning we
studied quite a lot manifolds and charts
and chart Transitions and we emphasized
very much that one chart may not be
enough to cover the whole
manifold and we also discussed that if
you know something in a
chart outside this chart domain there
may lie still parts of the real world
you haven't
seen now here with the Schwarz metric
and schwar shield coordinates you can
draw pictures of that and we'll do that
and you can live happily under the
illusion that this is covers the entire
world and you say yeah maybe here there
there their lines taken out because of
the breakdown of these polar coordinates
so to speak but other than that this
certainly covers the whole world well
today we'll find out that this is far
from the truth and we'll find out that
understanding this metric is only
possible really if we find other charts
that extend this chart quite a bit so
what seems to be a complete World in
fact is not so um the remark I wish to
make is uh the following
um when staring at this line element or
when staring at this metric for a
while well that's an important
theoretical technique to stare when
staring at this
metric for a
while two
questions naturally pose
themselves
the first question
is what happens what
exactly
happens at r equal 2
m and so if I ask this you say why am I
interested in Ral 2 m well at R = 2 m 1
- 1 is zero and worse 1 / by 0 is
infinity aha Why didn't you complain
when I said R runs from zero to Infinity
it doesn't it doesn't in these
coordinates R may run from 0 to 2 m
exclusively and then this may then run
again from 2 m to plus infinity it's
this Union this disjoint Union and the 2
m r equal 2 m cannot be assumed for this
metric because even if you ignore this
the metric becomes degenerate here so
one component is zero the other one is
infinity what a mess okay so first
inside this R which we might have
thought as a cozy radial parameter
cannot take this value
yes pardon
me yes but the point is that that is now
well we'll see if if so the point is
we'll start here and we'll see whether
this is all you have so if you suspect
that there might be something beyond the
zero to zero or minus infinity we'll
Discover
it why does nobody ask whether there's
something Beyond minus infinity and
something beyond Infinity
here that's the second question
second um is there
anything in the real
world
Beyond T minus infinity and t plus
infinity and that may sound like a very
silly question but in fact it isn't
because say well what what could be
beyond Infinity don't be ridiculous
remember this is just a chart so um the
idea is the following it's just a
question right we we'll see the idea is
the following if I have a map of
lens and it covers the entire area of
lens let's assume lens is
rectangular lens but then if you go
beyond that you come to the next town
okay why wouldn't I take this chart if
this is already a chart and I would blow
it up to a chart that's infinitely large
that's the whole plane I can do that
right I can take this interval from 0 to
one say or minus one to one and I can
blow it up in a one: one continuous
manner to the whole real
line then lens would be you would come
to the boundary of lens if you go to
Infinity on the chart or to minus
infinity does that imply that beyond
that Infinity in that chart there is
nothing more to the real world than
lints of course
not this could be the case here
so it's not a silly question so that's
the point you work with charts and you
need to understand what a chart means so
if you understand what a chart means and
we do understand that then you come up
with all kinds of questions uh and all
kinds of problems you didn't have before
and that's called
progress so the point is how do we get
insight into these questions because
obviously if we look at it from this
point of view we won't because these
coordinates themselves then are the
problem how do I transcend the
coordinates by using them so insight
into these
issues into these two and of course the
same could be the same point could be
made for R greater than infinity or
something like this right so inside into
these two
issues is
afforded by
stopping to
stare right that's also a technique so
you stare and then you stop to stare
because what is the inside the inside is
if we want to learn something about the
real world we should look at objective
objects not at chart dependent objects
but at objective
objects what is objective if you have a
metric well what is objective is for
instance what are the geodesics of the
metric they might then be EXP pressed in
those coordinates but as objects as such
they describe something in the real
world okay um look
at
geodesics of G
instead because that's something in the
real world that's how we transcend uh
the coordinates although we still work
in the coordinates we we look at an
object that's not coordinate dependent
okay so what we do first section is we
look at radially radial null
geodesics now this is uh just
terminology a null geodesic is a
geodesic whose tangent Vector at every
point is zero that's a n j it's the U
the um world line of a massless particle
so let's consider these in Schwarz
Shield
consider null
geodesic
in s CHD that's the short form for
Schwarz okay let's consider n geodesic
there so what do you need to do well you
need to to look at a uh at an action
for uh this massless particle and how do
you get this well you have this now you
have the g v gamma V gamma of Lambda uh
and in Schwarz Shield this becomes 1 - 2
m/ r
T do^ 2
minus 1 - 2 m / R inverse R do 2- R 2
Theta dot 2 + sin 2 Theta 5 dot
squ that is the action for a massless
geodesic if
you provide the information that it's a
n geodesic with the expression in
Brackets being zero that's the
additional condition now you say oh if I
plug this in it's zero well you mustn't
plug it in at this point at this point
you first need to vary and then you plug
in um and one
has in
particular the r equation of motion you
know you have an action you vary you can
vary with respect to various variables
and uh the one we are interested in is
the um no actually we interested in the
T equation of motion why did I always
write
R yes we're interested in the T equation
of motion in principle we're interested
in all but we'll see the T1 suffices
what's the T equation of motion well
it's the lran by T dot that gives you a
two *
this then the result derived minus the L
divided by T derived with respect to T
but there's no T in here so the T
equation of motion is actually 1 - 2 m /
r a factor of two I don't need T dot the
whole thing dotted equals zero right
that's the T equation of motion that
follows from there I would be crazy if I
evaluated this dot on here and on here
because I know the result is zero so can
I can eliminate the dot and immediately
have one integral of motion I know this
is some constant
K okay so it's my T equation of motion
and I have this null condition and with
these two alone so I can get extra
equations of motion from here but um I
will not need them because what I will
look at is only
consider
radial null
geodesics which means in addition to
these two conditions I already provide
that Theta ought to be constant and F
ought to be
constant which defines radial I'm
talking about a particle that falls in
radially without any Theta or F
component um changing so these are the
radial al6 and that uh is then the
integration of the other two which I
here do by assumption because I look at
a particular case now if I have this
null condition which means that the
square bracket is zero and I use the
equation of motion here I can do the
following I can um obtain
from the first box and the second box it
actually follows that r dot is plus or
minus K how do you see this well you
solve this one for T dot that's K
divided by the round bracket you plug it
in that gives you a k squar divided by
the round bracket squared so it gives
you a k squared I'm sorry so this is yes
so let's first do this is a k squ
divided by the round bracket minus you
have r dot squ divided by the round
bracket you multiply by the round
bracket you get this one and this is of
course the case if and only if r dot is
plus minus K okay this is just
insertion you you say interesting but
what do I learn from this well you learn
a great deal the dot here is this
parameter Lambda and we had an fine
parameterization therefore you can solve
this you can solve this you have two
Poss Solutions you learn that R of
Lambda is either plus or minus K *
Lambda right what does that mean it
means that if you just see K * Lambda
and Lambda is an fine parameter that
parameterizes your world line you see oh
constant times that is still an fine
parameter so you learn that the radial
coordinate can serve as a different
parameterization for your world line
without changing that it's Fally rzed
aha
hence we may
consider instead of solving for T of
Lambda we could solve for some T twiddle
of R which is the T of plus or minus K
Lambda if I write plus minus we have to
make a case
distinction okay so normally I would
solve these equations of motion for T of
Lambda R of Lambda Theta of Lambda F of
Lambda and then I have a
parameterization of the curve in the
space time
right but now because of the special
situation I see instead of
parameterizing by a parameter which I
could choose arbitrarily I choose the r
i can choose the r as an fine
reparameterization and I can express
directly the T in terms of R okay so I
get rid of the parameterization that's
kind of useful as we will see in a
second second so how does that work so
let's do case
a case a is of this plus minus I choose
the plus and then next second we choose
the minus so if I look at this case I
can calculate what's DT uh twiddle by
Dr so in physics it's often customed to
just write instead of T of Lambda one
writes T of R but of course the T
twiddle depends on r differently than
the t depends on the Lambda so it's
better to write it like this DT twiddle
by D what is this well you can think of
the chain rule um you can say you first
derive this uh T
twiddle with respect to Dot and then you
derive the r with respect to dot okay if
you do that uh then of course you get uh
a chain rule you get a uh in this case
plus K divided by now you um look at the
r uh sorry so the T ttle dot is this one
times the
t hold on a second times the
T it's the T dot times the K but the T
dot we had is
K divided
by this guy okay I'm sorry is so okay so
this is K K ided by this guy is 1 - 2 m
/ R and then from the r dot you get the
K so what you get here in total if you
expand by R is um R by Rus 2 m is that
right yes that's right okay so uh anyway
we know how this one uh increases there
and this can be
integrated so you know the derivative of
t t so you learn that t twiddle of R
equals r + 2 m Ln R minus 2 m that's the
integral as you very quickly see by
deriving this with with respect to R you
get 1 + 2 m / r - 2 m if you bring this
to the same denominator you get back to
this
guy okay so this is quickly uh solved
and that's it we found
the N desic well that's case a uh let's
quickly look at case b case b is if we
choose the minus sign here and we follow
a similar root and we get to T twiddle
of R so maybe we call this t plus and
this T minus t tdle of R is then minus r
minus 2 m Ln r - 2 m and um I calculate
yes so we have the derivative here so
these guys here you can check by looking
at the at the sign of this these guys up
there are the
outgoing null
geodesic see in a second why we call
them outgoing and these are the ingoing
or infalling ingoing null
geodesics well let's draw this
picture so so we
start with the TR Shield coordinates
T and A SCH Shield
coordinate
R there's the special point to M and I
just have some have some line here to
know where 2 m is but this is just in my
I'm
sorry so this is just in my mind this 2
m and now I start drawing these null
geodesics now let's look first at
the at the ingoing or the outgoing ones
so the T that's this this T here of
course the the other T is just with a
different parameter this T here is this
function of r so what happens if I come
from the right and I approach 2 m if I
approach 2 m the Ln goes to minus
infinity right goes to minus infinity so
then to minus infinity I add R I'm not
very impressed but the point is these um
outgoing
NCS uh they are like this so I should
use different
colors okay so the outgoing nescs let's
start with
them I start doing them in region in
this region here they like
this they all come they all go ASM
totically to
here and they go somehow like
this okay that's what they do they go on
like this that is for R greater than 2 m
for R equals Zer I must not even look at
it because I equal 0 is not part of the
chart now there is a second region where
can look at these guys at the outgoing
ones and it's the same story it's just
that the r is smaller so there they run
like
this it's always drawing this funny Ln
function there
okay so okay so these are the outgoing
ones the green Green in this outer
region and the blue ones in this inner
region that's just the geodesics in
Schwarz Shield coordinates so that's the
map of Lin in Lin there are light rays
running okay I mean you know Lin Is Not
A Spacetime piece but a space piece but
something like this so this is an
objective picture in those coordinates
but these guys mean something this is
what light does expressed in these
coordinates so now we need to look at
the ingoing Nal geod six and how do they
look like so there is this minus there
so um this is actually minus this up
here so I can everywhere take the
outgoing ones as they're called and I
flip them and I get the ingoing ones so
let's do it for this one here first um
so I need to what do I have down here I
need to reproduce here something like
this is too too steep here sh and then I
go here like
this so here ASM totically and then I go
away here the same thing I reproduce
this go ASM totically away not ASM
totically I go away and
here I approach ASM totically this here
and then finally this
one and I ASM
totically go here oh yeah that's a it
look doesn't look very good but it's
true
um I mean you know it's it's it's it's
an art to draw but that those are these
and then we have in the inner region we
have a similar
situation like this is this one this one
goes
like that ASM totically here and finally
uh which one don't I have I don't have I
don't have this one so this one goes
like like
so uh
so okay so maybe that's a little
confusing so let's be careful so the
outgoing ones so these guys would kind
of run in this
direction and
um so here the ingoing ones
are
yellow and
red okay so the yellow ones are ingoing
ones so they run in this
Direction and before I go to the inner
region let's observe that these are null
geodesics so at every point that
tangent to the cone which means that if
I well I draw the cone like this because
I suppress the other directions in the
diagram anyway that there must be a
light cone there like this there the
light cone must look I mean a light cone
at this point you know it lives in the
tangent space so I can only draw it
locally so uh roughly speaking in the
tangent space at this point I have this
light cone there I have this one they
have this one you can construct from
this you can see in the Schwarz Shield
coordinates what the cones look like
okay so in the schield coordinates cones
out here rather look like this okay but
the further you go in the more they're
squeezed but you observe although
they're squeezed they refuse to tilt or
something they they they always stand
upright like this okay H okay so let's
look at the um the geodesics uh uh
inside so the infalling ones uh these
guys actually run in this
direction and uh the blue ones they uh
the outgoing ones in this inside
Direction uh they run like uh hang on a
second
they the ingoing ones it's it's right I
think this one runs
like hang on a second they run up here
down here they they
write hang
on are they upside
down
okay not entirely sure that's
true yes that's right you you have to to
orient but nevertheless here
I thought they stand like this I'm now a
little bit puzzled here let let me think
for one second please so don't go out in
out in I also think it should be like
this now
okay okay but that doesn't hurt us okay
however they stand okay um so we have a
situation like this and um yeah that's
it those are the geodesics of Schwartz
child and now you look at this and you
say
hm haven't I read in the popular
literature SCH is a black hole that at
2m there is an event horizon where light
can only go in and massive matter but it
can't come out well it doesn't look it
can go in right because any null
geodesic approaches this 2m approaches
it approaches it approaches it and
however far you go you will not cross
it so light does not fall
in maybe we overlooked something now
think again of the question about
Lind so assume Lin is A Spacetime region
rather than just a space region as long
as I'm in this chart which extends to T
to Infinity I do not
cross well but maybe this chart only
covers everything up to the boundary of
lens then the chart is at
Infinity but the it doesn't mean that
Beyond Lind there's no more to the real
world so may it's true I mean what we
calculate of course is true within the
Schwarz Shield
chart an out an outer infalling nesic
rad infalling nesic will not cross the
Horizon
yes
yes yeah yeah yeah I think this one must
be oriented like this they must like be
like that
right they are like this okay let's um
yes yes now I know why I'm okay let's
um let's not spoil the moment it's not
the crucial point right now okay um it's
it's right I also think that they they
are like this okay but um let's look at
this what happens here um so the yellow
and the red ones are the infalling ones
right that we got from the infalling
solution from ingoing solution Now isn't
it already a little bit
suspicious that the the infalling ones
they run up to Infinity here in this
chart say to the to the city boundary of
Lind and then assume you had a a map of
lens and you see that there is somebody
who lives here and he commutes to work
every day up to
Infinity right because I stretched this
to infinity and then in the evening he
goes and visits his his parents right so
so the point is there people I mean I
shouldn't say it's the same one but
people are kind of walk running here
every day uh and you has have also
people running here well you might
suspect that there's something Beyond
Lind and that Beyond lens they actually
return you see what I mean even if your
chart doesn't show that
right that's in fact the case here but
we need to find out whether it's really
the case you run here with the yellow
ones and you come in with these ones the
point is beyond the chart uh really the
particles cross the Horizon now how do
we see this is just a a suspicion from
our thinking about charts that that
could be the case the question is is it
the
case question no okay so
um so the question oh and I should have
of course when before I wrote the
integral is this and that I should have
written plus constant because that makes
the different ones right when I
integrate plus constants okay sorry okay
um so uh the idea to follow this idea is
to introduce the Edington
finklestein
coordinates
question you keep knocking without
asking okay
good Edington finlin is a new chart and
uh in order to figure out what's really
going on uh there is a brilliantly
simple
idea
brilliantly
simple
idea
change on the
domain of the Schwarz Shield
coordinates no where else how would
you change on the domain of the scheld
coordinates to different
coordinates
such that in those new
ingoing null geodesics only the ingoing
ones ingoing null geodesics because
we're interested in their
fate
appear as straight
lines of of
slope minus
one aha can this be done well of course
it can be
done this is
achieved by the new coordinate T
bar which of course can be expressed as
a function of the old
coordinates and if you wish this is the
chart transition
map it's given as T the old t plus 2 m
Ln Rus 2 m so remember before the null
geodesic had uh so
recall that uh the
ingoing
null
geodesic
was given by T twidle of R that's now
just the function uh equals that
describes the null geodesic equals r no
minus
r plus 2 m Ln R minus 2 m so here we had
an R but here we now have an T but the
point is we want that this here in the
new T Bar coordinates in fact is a
straight line well this is easily this
is easily seen because uh this this was
the T from there before so you have a t
plus 2 m
Ln um no wrong you have to solve for
this T and plug it here so you have T
Bar minus 2 m Ln R minus 2
m equal so this is the n geodesic in
schw child
coordinates and now now we reformulate
this same equation in the other
coordinates by replacing the T by this
minus this one equals - r - 2 m Ln r - 2
m and here I forgot plus constant I have
it here plus constant and you see this
one goes against this one that means in
the new
coordinates the equation is given by
minus r plus constant which is precisely
what we wanted we wanted a new T
coordinate such that the null geodesic
appears under this slope so let's draw a
picture
yes let's draw a
picture so this is now the new T Bar
coordinate we have the r we have the 2 m
2 m but now you need to tell me the
infalling outer ones had what
color the infalling outer ones had the
color or you use probably different
colors par me nobody
remembers no I think it was either blue
or
green the the out here incoming yellow
these were yellow okay good so these are
now slope
one slope one here there's nothing
because I didn't have that but in both
regions the transformation yields this
for an infalling N
geodesic plus constant it's the next
infalling null geodesic the old lines as
you can see um and yet another one in
Falling n they're all parallel lines of
slope minus one okay that's what they
are aha what is it with the outgoing
null
geodesics okay what is it with the
outgoing null
G6 I got them like like this but with a
plus sign here but if I do this I still
replace the left hand side by this take
it to the other side but now there was
already a plus here and there so the
outgoing ones have T Bar equals uh minus
uh no not minus R equals plus r because
there's an overall plus here plus r and
then plus 4 M Ln r - 2 m Plus Conant
ahuh so the two changes to a four but it
doesn't look nicer so it is not the case
that by this transformation we also got
the outgoing ones in a nice nice fashion
by the way um so I I should have
probably drawn these inner ones here by
by the Orange Line because I had
different colors I had different colors
before for the ones inside and outside
right remember so it's like this and
these ones here whatever color they had
blue or green was blue
outside anyway they're still like this
but they become the The Singularity here
becomes multiplied by two okay so
qualitatively it still
looks like
this okay these are still the outgoing
ones here and inside it still looks like
um it still looks
like
this stuff like that
okay now let's draw in this chart the
cones again well the cones for the
outgoing ones somehow like this
and uh the ones in here in green and
blue so these guys go like
this and these here go like
that and so the
cones
um are like
so okay and let's draw the cones out
here have a cone here again I mean I add
this little circle that doesn't really
belong to the two-dimensional picture
but then you have a right the right idea
where the little cones it but now you
see something is no it's all always is
fine because you can now draw the one
that runs here really close close close
close close close close close close and
only up here goes away okay and here you
have this
cone and there you have this
cone okay and uh and here this is an
interesting
point you have this cone and you see the
closer now you go to the Horizon if the
Horizon was there but it isn't right
it's not a part of our original SCH
Shield coord if the Horizon was there
they would all conspire to stand there
like this the cones do you see
that aha okay so that's the case now the
question is what has happened
well what happened is we made an
innocent coordinate transformation
inspired by the idea that I want to see
how somebody comes to this in the
previous picture uh the ingoing nescs
also approach The Horizon but I now
choose coordinates such that approach
The Horizon in a straight line which is
just a coordinate thing but
then the one so in the previous chart
they went up here and these came from
down here and what I do by this
coordinate transformation I go to a T
and then the closer I go to the Horizon
the more I pull a point from plus
infinity down because if I'm on the
horizon a point that was previous TR R
is now the point t plus this
R and this for R to 2 m becomes minus
infinity so the point is I took the
previous diagram and go to the Horizon
and at the Horizon I pull down and I
pull points down from
Infinity this point here was previously
at Infinity this point that doesn't
exist here was previously Infinity this
one was also at Infinity this one was
also at Infinity all this little
necklace of points that are here I
pulled them down from
Infinity by this coordinate
transformation
and hence what previously looked
like up to
Infinity at this R equals 2
m and
then back from
Infinity I pulled that
down in such a way and not only here I
also pull it down here and here and here
but the further I go to the right the
less I pull I pull the most namely from
up Infinity down to finite value here at
the point R equals 2 m a little bit
right of that I only pull a finite
distance okay it's only here that I pull
infinitely much a little bit here I put
a finite here even less finite and so on
such that this line becomes straight and
I pulled up this point at Infinity here
I pull it to here and then this
guy looks like this
that's funny right but uh that's exactly
it I went beyond the confines of the
chart of Lind which was a chart that was
blown up to Infinity although it only
covered in quotation marks the finite
area in the real world okay so that's
this diagram and now of course you say
what is the problem with this 2 m bit
there is none so I include these single
points which were not part of the
Schwarz chart so what I do is I say I
now have a new chart so
consider the new
chart V comma
y while
ux was the Schwarz Shield coordinate
chart okay so the previous one we call
ux and now we have a new one UV and you
know that the
intersection no that V if you take out U
that all that maybe better to write U
Union just now the domain Union with the
Horizon here so these points here this
line This dash line I call the
Horizon for reasons where it's going to
discuss in a second and now this Horizon
well at least in the real world it's the
Horizon so it's the chart image of the
Horizon so U together with the
Horizon that's V so Schwarz Shield only
covers
this and now we made the chart bigger
but in such a way that on the overlap
which is just U on the overlap uh it
coincides that's how we constructed it
yes restrict our
only because I mean
no the point is you need you need both
geodesics in order to spend a coordinate
system how can
I well they're outgoing nescs but
they're not future
pointing so you can't you don't have
particles run along them so that's the
the old idea um if you're at a point and
the g defines the double
cone and uh a curve a vector standing
inside here is as much time like or say
null uh this Vector
here is as much null as this Vector is
they're both
null and
hence uh
this is a n geodesic and the
same this is a n
geodesic I didn't say I want to look at
ingoing Future
pointing outgoing part Future pointings
Okay okay so so the distinction only
comes when you have the time orientation
okay so okay good okay so but indeed um
there is in fact a coordinate chart
that's that not called Edington finlin
but kusal they're also the outgoing ones
run at the same time at
45° I I'll comment on that but uh let's
first continue here what we want to do
so now we change to new coordinates the
picture looks nice and convinces us okay
there's something going on we now see
really these guys do cross this Horizon
uh without any problem it was just an
artifact of the previous chart which
pretended to be a very big chart but it
was just unduly blown up so really
beyond Infinity there was much to be
pulled down okay so that's this but this
is just the picture the picture is very
useful we constructed the picture from
formula but what we should really do we
should calculate the metric in the new
coordinates so now
calculate the Schwarz Shield metric G
you see the metric remains means the
metric you that's an AB object in the
real world now calculate the Schwarz
Shield metric G with respect to Edington
finl Stein
coordinates
Edington finle
Stein
coordinates how does one do that I mean
you know it in theory but let's do this
once in practice so you have a new
coordinate T Bar that depends on the old
coordinates like t + 2 m Ln r- 2
m uh that's it and you have a new R
which depends on the old
coordinates like the old R you have a
new Theta that depends on the old
coordinates like the old Theta and you
have a new fi that depends on the old
coordinates like the old fi
informally speaking we only changed the
T Bar coordinate but not informally
speaking uh you have a new R coordinate
it just happens to be the old one okay
so you change set of coordinates from
unbar coordinates to barred coordinates
so of course in the terminology from
before I have uh
y0 to
Y3 are the B
coordinates
right I just use this nomenclature
because it's a little bit easier to
remember and the old uh the old x
coordinates
are called like this okay so this is
just different names but I try to make
connection to the general formalism okay
so what do you need to do if you want to
know the new components if you want to
know the new
components um g in the Y system that's
the new system and you want to know the
ab component well you better take
the component MN in the X system and you
do
DXM by DX uh DXM by d y a dxn by dyb is
that the right way
around yes it
is okay so this is the coordinate
transformation uh the comp the com the
transformation of components of a metric
from the X system the old one into the
new system Schwartz Shield coordinates
adding finlin coordinates which we like
better okay so what do we need to do
well we need to calculate X by y x by y
are the old ones expressed derived with
respect to the new ones oh dear then we
have to invert this
guy yeah we can do this everything can
be done but um let me show you a trick
that always works you always choose the
direction that suits you better in this
case I don't want to calculate X by y I
calculated y by calculate y by
X and you learned and you checked in the
tutorials that if you know this Matrix
row column that this is the inverse
Matrix you remember so we can calculate
this one and then we invert The Matrix
let's do this once because this some I
mean here you may be able to invert and
it's very quick but let's do this once
as a
as a check so how does this go well you
need to say what you mean this is the
row index and this is the column index
so for one one or for 0 0 you derive the
zero with respect to zero this one with
respect to T that's a clear one
right then you uh continue in this row
so you stay with the zero you derive
this with respect to the r what do you
get you get 2 m / r r - 2 m is that
right that's right um you derive the
same one with respect to the Theta is
zero and with respect to the f is zero
you derive this one with respect to T no
t in it with respect to R yes with
respect to Theta with respect to five
derve this one with respect to T to R to
Theta gives a one to f z this one with
respect to t z r0 Theta 0
51 that's the
Matrix okay comes in useful to practice
this for exams and stuff so um you get
this thing now what's the inverse of
that Matrix uh
dxb by or DX a by
dyb this should be the
inverse well let's guess 1 - 2 m by r -
2 m
one
zero one one and the remaining ones all
zero
okay let's check where this is the
inverse so we come with this Matrix from
the left to this one this time this
gives a one row * column gives a one
okay that's the one
we want to get the identity so we take
this row times this column this is um 1
*
this minus 1 * the same is
zero 0 0 and so on you can check this is
the
inverse
okay aha so now we have this inverse all
that we need to do now is we need to
evaluate component by component what the
new components
are I think I'll do this in the
middle so I can still peek at the other
Blackboard so we're simply finding the
compon components of the metric in the
Edington finstein coordinates according
to the general rules we worked
out thank you so we start with g y uh
the z0 component which you could also
call the T Bar T Bar component it
doesn't matter you know we use this uh
rather flexible notation equals well in
order to get the Zer Z what you need is
you need the y z down
here now here you you have in the X
system the MN you have a
DXM
dxn now remember that this is the metric
in Schwarz Shield coordinates the
components of the metric in the Schwarz
Shield coordinates you remember that was
diagonal so we only need to check for m
equals n 0 0 1 1 22 3 3 and we always
have to write this here so let's do this
so we start for g0 0 here to g0000 0 is
um 1 - 2 m/ R in Schwarz Shield
coordinates you agree that's g0 0 in the
schield coordinates and we multiply by
x0 by y0 x0 by y0 so the thing squared
x0 by y0 is a one a one squared is a
one one times now
comes plus why plus well it's a
summation convention there must be a
plus now comes the one one component of
Schwarz child but the one one component
of Schwarz is
minus um 1 over 1us 2 m / R remember
that's the signature that comes in here
so uh we could use this minus to make
this to a minus and then we multiply by
X1 by y0 X1 by y0 X1 by y0 is minus this
guy sorry is this guy squared so it's uh
- 2
m by 1 - 2 m / R is that right no by r -
2 m by r - 2 m all
squared plus summation convention comes
the
G
33 time X3 y0 X3
y0 is zero the same for X4 y0 X4 y 0
also zero so there's nothing more plus 0
+ 0 is the full summation convention
yields 1 - 2 m / r - 4 m^ 2 / r - 2 m
squared times and I expand this one by r
r r 1 minus 2 m
no uh I
right an R up here which is one/ R down
there R minus 2 m right yes I divide by
R and I get this up there uh so
huh I'm
confused pardon
me
confused
is this right what's written here okay
it's right what's written here so I just
need to take this to the Sim so but a
third power
here I'm
confused I take it all out of
what so tell me what you write and we
check whether it's true you tell me okay
so
Square what do you
write okay so
um
yes pardon
me you need to speak louder I don't hear
ah yes yes yes yes so the second one is
wrong the first one was right was the 0
by0 and next one is one by zero but one
you see uh it's important that you
remember this is the row I need to go
here so actually look at this one right
thank you thank
you okay
so the SEC so the first one was right
the 0 0 one anybody gets that right but
the second one already failed you go
through this is plus 0+ 0+ 0 and in fact
the result is indeed 1 - 2 m / R which
means the z0 component in the Edington
Stein coordinates is the same a
component is the same as
before
okay so now we calculate the one one is
is there still a
question now we calculate the one one
component according to the same scheme
but now we go with respect to D1 D1 DXM
dxn GX MN and now of course we need to
look at all the ones in this column and
multiply them each time squared y squar
well because that's the same and this is
uh diagonal so only those appear so we
get a - 2
m by r - 2
m uh and we get that
twice and we multiply with the 0 0
component which is 1 - 2 m /
R plus we get the next one which is a
one and get another
one and we multiply with the one one
component which is minus one
over uh um 1 minus 2 m/ R is that right
I think that's
right so let's try to to get this
straight so what is this this is 4 m^ 2
/ r - 2 m in bracket
squared and here you have r - 2 m / R
it's the same
thing plus no minus one
over r - 2 m and we put an R here again
that's right no and then this Square
here goes against this Factor up
here and then you get 4 m
2 by r - 2
m this over r
here
minus r - 2
m
r equals r- 2
m and uh
uhuh is this right 4 m^ 2 by R let me
see what this is right
minus
r can this be brought to any meaningful
form so I do what I divide by
R so I I I expand or I cancel what do I
Do by
what by times
R aha okay so so this is 4 m^ 2 - R 2 by
r^ 2 - 2 m r and
now ah okay now I start understanding R
minus 2 m r and now you want the third
binomial or
something something like that
right who's
laughing so this is minus if I cancel
this against this I get a minus 2 m + r
by R uh and that is okay that's what it
is
right because 2 m minus r / r - 2
m i I think that's that's approximately
right uh so this is min - 1 + 2 m /
R okay that's it and um okay as you can
see I have serious difficulty performing
these
calculations as I
say very strong yes okay so um uh uh
there's yet nevertheless one we need to
calculate that's the 01 one but I won't
bore you with that it works according to
the same line along the same lines only
that now you have the the these others
la la la I won't embarrass myself even
more so so so the result if you do this
properly is minus 2 m by R so that means
we produced an off diagonal element and
of course this one is the
same as the
gy 1 Z because it's symmetric they're
both this here and all the others are
unchanged all others remain
unchanged so they're the same in the X
in the Y system so what we get
result we get Schwarz child in Addington
fle
coordinates how does it look like it's G
is the abstract tensor that has nothing
to do with the coordinate system I take
the 0 0 component 1 - 2 m / R DT bar
tensor DT bar because with respect to
the DT bar now I
get minus and that's the thing I get
this mixed element this is min - 2 m
over R and this is true for the DT bar
tensor Dr but also for the Dr tensor DT
bar right I mean this is this element on
the right upper right and lower left
then comes the minus actually they're
all pluses but because there the minus
in here this minus 1 + 2 n m / R Dr bar
tensor Dr bar it continues but what
continuous is the old stuff minus r SAR
of the Theta bar well strictly speaking
I have to call the r the r bar right so
D Theta bar Tor D Theta bar uh plus sin
s Theta bar d f bar tensor D5 bar but
it's good custom to drop the bars on the
RS because really the r was not
changed okay and the bars on the feters
although very strictly speaking they
belong there but they are still the old
coordinates like in Schwarz shild
okay okay so this is the uh Schwartz
Shield metric and Addington finstein
coordinates uh and
that's a result that's useful yes is it
just for reasons that you start with the
and it from there or
direct well it would be bad pedagogical
reasons because the schwartzel chart is
not a very good chart but the point is
we start with the idea well we have a
spherically symmetric solution let's
start with the polar coordinates that
come to mind if you want to describe a
spherically symmetric Solutions in the
time Direction well let's say that goes
from minus infinity to plus infinity we
allow everything we think then we plug
this into Ein sense equation we get the
solution in schield coordinates now this
teaches us a lesson it teaches us the
lesson that whatever chart you come up
with which you think might be a good
chart to cover virtually everything the
Einstein equations May report back to
you look at the solution look at what
the geodesics are doing and if you have
geodesics running to somewhere and they
do this in finite parameter time in
finite fine parameter time especially
also the Tim likee ones and they don't
seem to hit any boundary but they stop
because the chart ends right there are
chances that your chart is chosen too
small although formally it's blown up to
the whole
plane but that may be just an artifact
so in fact the coordinates we thought
are good coordinates by intuition by
making an anzat blah blah blah blah it
turns out that's just a small part of
what the I equations report back to you
do you now see how important it is that
we get this idea right what's the real
world and what's the chart because
otherwise you say if if you only think
in charts this would be the most
mysterious procedure to change to
another chart and to to insert points I
mean it is a magical procedure to go
beyond Infinity but if you think of
charts some very normal thing are
Apparently one shows a very funny chart
so yes also how people discover yes yes
yes so so in the beginning they took the
other coordinates and then one tried to
understand what this R equals 2 m means
and Einstein first didn't understand
because he he thought the manifold ends
there he thought you only have this
outer solution and the other one is
another solution of another
SpaceTime right because he was still
thinking in charts a lot and and and so
with time people realized we have to um
uh we have to study this at the level of
differential geometry and so there are
many indicators why I mean I gave you an
intuitive indicator they run out and
they come in and okay so the technical
thing you do is you ask is the space
time maximally extended now what is that
you look at
geodesics and you see whether geodesics
continue for infinite
parameter it's a complete geodesic we
had this notion of completeness or
whether the geodesic stops because it
hits a
singularity but the geodes bics of
Schwarz child that went out the chart up
there in the Schwarz coordinates they
didn't hit any Singularity and if you
followed the fine parameter which we
didn't do you would have seen it's not
fine parameter Infinity you can also do
this for for for time like geodesics
where then have the natural parameter
the length the time uh the the proper
time by which you um can um parameterize
them and you see they run there in
finite time it's like you you have this
map of
lens
and you see that your father in the
morning is driving away like
this and after half an hour he has
reached this
point and then 10 hours
later he comes back so the suspicion is
that he did something here
okay whereas if the chart was a
different
one and you would drive in in proper
time parameters
ation and you never arrive up there
right you never so you can maybe you
come closer and closer and closer but no
matter how much you extend your proper
time for a time like judic you never
arrive at this boundary well then
there's no problem then you have no
suspicion that there's something beyond
the boundary so this is an informal
discussion of the notion of maximal
extension
yes no as I said I made this fine
distinction an fine parameterization
which includes the proper time but also
for n geodesics you can have an aine
parameterization which is actually
always the case if your uh
geodesics uh satisfy equal zero rather
than uh Shai times V gamma you remember
the distinction between Auto parallels
and uh so parallel and auto um parallel
and parallel transport and so on so this
is um Pinocchio with the nose always
being zero or something something okay
no Pinocchio not lying the non- Ling
Pinocchio okay so also for nescs that
makes sense okay and what comes out is
the fine
parameterization and that you can can
use yes is
there by well the cor gave us gave us
this yes are well in enal you you have
if you go to Crazy coordinates like
those
ones then the whole Matrix is full of
terms okay and if you have these cross
terms um it doesn't look static anymore
it may still be stationary because none
of the components depends on the new
time so d by DT bar is still a killing
Vector field a time like killing Vector
field you might have the suspicion it's
not stationary anymore because for
stationarity there is a coordinate
system where this goes away but you know
that's only fake because in another
system in the schwat coordinate it goes
away okay so the the um the first
approximation to to your answer to your
question is no there's no deeper meaning
it's just different coordinate
nevertheless cross terms one usually
discusses
yeah further question no okay fine so we
have the um uh this in the new in the
new coordinate
um okay so
uh we have the final uh bit that's cral
coordinates and I won't do this in
detail because you can read it up there
are many good books that do that uh but
the idea
is um do
further coordinate
transformations
changes such
as to
also have the
outgoing null
geodesics
appear as
straight
lines now of slope + one in the
chart and I will just draw you the
resulting uh picture of Schwarz shield
in cuscal coordinates look up how
they're defined very roughly speaking
for the Edington finlin coordinates at
the Horizon we pulled down from Infinity
we pulled down the points you
remember now here you also pull some up
from from Below L very roughly speaking
and you don't only do this at the
Horizon but the Horizon you do this
infinitely and something like like this
right you you do it like this and um
very roughly speaking and the
resulting
picture of schwar
child in those cral
coordinates
is and there's a surprise and I try not
to spoil it so in the cuscal coordinates
the Schwarz sheld space
time looks like this it's the
interior this is the outer region so
this this inside is the black hole well
before I should have already drawn how
it where the black hole is in the
Edington fle stance of course to the
left from your point of view of the
Horizon right and then of course you
think of this rotated and you have one
more Dimension and of course this two
Dimensions suppressed now this here is
the outer
region and this is the black hole region
and this is the
singularity and here now really all
light rays run all infalling
ones go like
this chop and they hit the
singularity chop they hit the
singularity but also the outgoing ones
they go like
this this one evades the singularity
this one evades the singularity this one
is already inside the black hole
everything that's inside the black hole
invariably Falls in into
there
okay but there's a
surprise so this is we say okay this is
other coordinates so what before was
there it's now here like there and okay
this The Singularity is space likee
because it was before you see before the
singularity was but then the cone stood
like there so the singularity was space
likee you see what I mean so that that's
that's fine that looks
good the Edington finl Stein that we had
before which corresponds to this in
cuscal coordinates is still not the
maximal
extension it turns
out
it turns out there is a second outer
region we didn't see before it's the
outer region two whereas this was the
outer region one was which was the only
one that was visible in Schwarz child
and the only one visible in Edington
finlin but all of a sudden that was not
the maximal extension there is another
outer
region and there is and
now you will rightfully be
shocked you see that these guys they
actually came from here and these guys
they actually came from
here oh that's a terrible
situation because this is a singularity
all hell breaks loose at the
singularity and from there stuff comes
and moves here that means an
observer going about his business here
right so something an observer going
about his business right here will
receive information from The
Singularity we should be able to see
singularities if this really is physical
but as a solution of Einstein's equation
it's the maximal one and uh so this is
called a white hole it's the black hole
things can only fall in but never come
out because of the time orientation from
the white hole stuff can only come out
and not fall in you see this here
because uh light always runs at this
here and uh if the other light then runs
here like
that then you see that massive stuff
could also at most run out
you
see aha so there's this whole second
part to this and now you can start
asking questions like what on Earth
happens
here and you can study so in this
Edington finstein coordinat so this is a
new coordinate t double bar that goes in
this direction you can ask what actually
happens I draw the diagram new
because otherwise it's too too much in
one
diagram what happens so CH chck chck
chck chck chck one two cheuck check
cheuck cheuck
cheuck ha so again this is Schwarz child
maximally extended but that's the end of
the game okay um now you can ask what
happens if I look at spatial
sections that evolve like this
there this
one this one and this one so um if we
look at this one
here this is part of the outer region
which we believe to understand right and
so on now look at this one this is this
outer region which we believe to
understand the point is what happens so
these are like two universes which have
no causal contact to each other because
no body in here can signal anything to
someone here can you see that because
light always runs like this you would
have to Signal faster than the speed of
light in order to send a signal from in
here to here
agree that means nobody here can signal
anything to anybody here and nobody here
can signal anything to anybody here if
you look at this level but remember that
we suppressed two Dimensions so at every
Point here there is still a two sphere
attached
of various size it depends you need to
look at the line element to study that
and it turns out that as T progresses
and you look at these green guys here
can you see the green on green or yeah
um there is a topology change of the
spatial
sections topology
change of the
spatial sections in
green
okay and so at if we look at um at this
one here at T equals z you can read this
yes I think I feel uncomfortable I use
another color so um let's look at this
one here this whole one at T equals z
that actually looks as follows the
spatial bit
right
it looks like a
throat uh I suppressed one dimens so
this is a
two-dimensional spatial so I suppressed
one one spatial
Dimension
suppressed and it's supposed what in
this picture is just this
here okay so this one
here corresponds to this upper
half and this one here corresponds to
the lower
half but if you're here
before things happen so let me draw dra
this here at this time it looks like
like this I do it now even one dimension
more reduced but this is the throat okay
now if you uh move in time down here all
of a sudden this will be
disconnected it will look like this so
this
part is this guy and that
part is that
guy so there two separate outer regions
right but here they come closer and
closer together hang on a second that's
a so now here they're the F the farthest
apart they're the farthest apart so from
here from here they now
join looks like this then they move
apart then they join
again and then they do that again and
that is what uh so that's the Evolution
here if you Pro proceed in this T Bar
Bar okay crazy stuff is happening there
uh well this requires careful analysis
of the full line element of cuscal which
I didn't write down I only wrote down
the diagram that suppresses this okay so
then you can start speculating so this
is called an Einstein Rosen
bridge and you can start speculating
whether you may provide
additional Global conditions for how
this goes and then you have here the
throat and if so had the throat before
now it connected here like this you
could provide this by hand something
like this you would then call a
wormhole that would mean you start for
Schwartz shield with a different
topology from the start and stuff like
that so you can imagine crazy stuff that
solves the Einstein equations and these
are all uh possible solutions if you
make the right Provisions okay
anyway this is the maximally extended SW
child if you say let's go in all that
directions now uh that looks rather
crazy because this white ho thing is
totally nuts and in fact one uh is uh
one has the idea to say that should be
physically excluded because the theory
becomes highly nonpredictive because
everything would come from a singularity
but at the singularity the theory breaks
down whatever originates here you don't
know how to write down initial
conditions whatever you think that
quantum theory takes over you would have
a fully non-predictive Theory theory if
this was really realized like that so
what uh one really believes is that for
instance if you have so this is should
interpret it as a vacuum solution so
there's no mattera producing the Schwarz
child it's just a vacuum solution as
niik jini explained that makes perfect
sense we have this mass m in there but
that's the ADM mass of the SpaceTime and
so on okay you can consider it a pure
vacuum solution however if you don't
consider it a pure vacuum solution then
you might think that you have some
matter so I think again in the original
schwarzfeld coordinates you have some
matter uh falling in lots of matter and
on under their own gravitation they fall
together until they're
inside all the matter is in so this is a
time a picture in Schwartz child time T
until at some point a horizon
forms because so much matter is in here
and it's so so dense that it's inside
its own Schwarz child uh Horizon and
then you have a singularity here in the
original Schwarz child coordinates well
that's already the picture where you
rotated where you have this uh could
think of half the picture or something
like this this would be um more like a
realistic picture and then you don't
have this white hole bit okay um however
what do I really mean by this and is
there an even better way uh to
understand oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I I
drew the wrong
picture so so this I am sorry I already
Drew okay I already Drew Drew it's not
true okay it's not true that this is the
picture in chrisal coordinates I'm sorry
this is already the so-called
Penrose diagram of the same and the
Penrose diagram we'll do in the next
lecture I am sorry I'm sorry but the
point is why I drew this is because the
um the actual Cru scal I'm sorry that's
that's very silly was very silly of me
so um it's all true I said but I drew
the wrong picture so the crusar picture
looks like this there are the
singularity so there is here a
hyperbola hyperbola and the singularity
lies
here and so that's that's really the
cuscal coordinates and the singularity
lies
here and this extends
everywhere right so this ex extends in
all directions to
Infinity not the part that I shade here
the part I shade is not part of the
picture so this extends to Infinity in
all directions the part I'm shading
here does not belong to the picture but
everything that's not shaded is
crusar and indeed geodesics null
geodesics you see why I confused this
um and the null geodesics here they all
run like
this they hit
here they hit here you call this the
black hole you call this the white hole
right um uh you have other other null
geodesics running like here they come
from infinity and they run like
there stuff like this this is the
Horizon of the black hole seen from here
this is the Horizon of the black hole
see from here the only difference is
that this really extends to
everywhere and extends here to
everywhere and the only difference to
the Penrose diagram is that here one did
an additional trick one took the null
directions and one compact
them in this way in order to bring the
whole space time so only what is inside
here is a picture of the space time okay
in order to not have the problem to say
well what really happens here at
Infinity because it's so difficult to
think about it you compactify along the
null coordinates and that will be the
topic of the next lecture in order to
compactify this picture to this and then
you have a pen Rose diagram and this
penous diagram but you see it's it's
virtually the same apart from this being
compactified so I I please apologize
that I drew this and I said it's in a
crisal coordinates again this is not in
cuscal coordinates this is in
conformally rescaled coordinates whereas
this is the picture in the cuscal
coordinates that's very similar and um
we'll discuss the construction of such
pendos diagrams where you can really fit
an entire SpaceTime on a small sheet of
paper well if you suppress two
coordinates and and stuff like this okay
and here because the cones always
everywhere stand up like this you can
very easily see which regions are
connected causally connected to which
regions and which are not where from
where to where you can send
signals okay so that was it about uh the
black holes uh the Schwartz Shield black
hole there is a charged black hole
that's called Ry nstr solution it's a
bit more complicated there is a rot
ating and charged black hole that's
called the care solution so rotating
black hole is no longer spherically
symmetric in space but in space only
cylindrically symmetric of course it
rotates there's a distinguished by
Direction in space and so on and so
there are many different black holes uh
however there's much to be said about
black holes for instance black holes
don't have hair so if they form uh and
one believes that the curve black hole
is the most general form it can rotate a
black hole that only has mass one Mass
one charge and one angular momentum you
can say but shouldn't there be black
holes that have a little bump here and a
little bump there so black holes that
are not like spherical or cylindrical if
they're rotating um well the answer is
no right so there there's a very it's
very general because um with time all
the asymmetries would be radiated Away
by gravitational
radiation okay so black holes are really
um a very special class of course you
can um the abstract definitions for
Horizons and the different types of
Horizons and so on so all of that if you
want to learn that you go to literature
and read a book on black holes but these
are the basic ideas that we dis um
displayed here and from there you need
to take it yourself thank you very
much yes may I ask a question yes so I
have feeling that if one reaches now
this horizont between out reg and the
black hole some strongly nonlinear
behavior in time is going on we did some
rescaling some coordinate
Transformations yes can now interpret
this if an observer yeah goes into the
black hole and how his clock arising
this Horizon does the clock going faster
is my impr from whose point of
view in my lifetime would I reach the
horiz is my my recognition slowed down
or is it does it go faster so this is I
do not even know the non linearity now
in which in which direction the scaling
the nonlinearity is going yes yes so so
the point is somebody falling into the
black hole for somebody out here it
appears that that person will approach
more and more and more and more The
Horizon but you can discuss from this
picture that if somebody can we have
some um so you can imagine from this
picture somebody falls into this black
hole as a massive Observer and there's a
massive Observer say out here looking
Observer is always massive um then you
will receive information by this guy
sending I'm still alive I'm still alive
I'm still alive and so on well the point
is actually the massive one in this uh
Penrose diagram we'll see this later
will always arrive here as a geodesic so
this guy will receive information from
this guy till the end of his own
lifetime uh which may be Infinity which
here is infinity you will live
infinitely long here as an observer this
guy's clock here goes like 1 Hour 2
hours 3 hours boop I'm in the black hole
four hours 5 hours and so on but the guy
out here will wait for millions of years
and he will only see that the guy comes
closer and closer and closer in his time
you wait a million years and the other
guy hasn't fallen in although on his own
clock he fell in after an
hour sounds very strange but that's his
clock and that's his clock okay so let's
reconvene at quarter
past